sometimes comes off sleazy so that's why
I can call it promotion or communicating
and the point of it is that you can have
the best product in the world but if no
one knows about it what's the point of
the product I mean I would like I'd like
to know uh for instance if there is
someone out there that does a heart
surgery or valve replacement without
having to have open heart but if I don't
know I would just go to the hospital and
say I want to have open heart surgery
and I want to get the valve replaced but
if I know because they promote it well I
can go now and call that expert and then
go so this is why I think it's it's it's
so important hey it's EV car Michael and
I watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things too it's like your morning coffee
but for your goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
hash believe in the comments below so I
can celebrate with
you and communicating and promoting so
when I did my I remember my book
promotion on of the education of a
bodybuilder Simon and Cho to wanted to
have it you sell 100,000 copies MH so I
said well I want to have it on the best
seller list I don't know no bodybuilding
magazine was ever on the best seller
list forget about that I said well I
said this give it a shot how many cities
do we go and promote the book and he
says well here's six cities I I suggest
and so I said to him I said why don't we
go to 30 cities you're crazy so he was
laughing but then I put together
schedule and for 30 cities in 30
days and I was crisscrossing America I
was going from 90 degree temperature in
Miami up to Minnesota the there was like
in know below zero so it was literally
like
100° temperature differences in the same
day so this is how much I Cris crossed
this country and it was absolutely
fantastic we w a bestseller list we sold
you know 250,000 hard covers or whatever
it was and it was like a total smash as
a bodybuilding and fitness book wow and
so this is again over and over again
I've seen that not just the willpower to
succeed but to be able to sell and to
communicate and to be out and actually
talk about it you know uh I think it's
important to let people know step number
two is practice the 202020 rule with
Robin charma any new skill can be
installed with 66 days of practice MH
and so a lot of PE we all can change we
all can embrace the 5 a.m. club and join
the club so we start our days well we
just don't give it enough time so the
first thing is make a commitment for 66
days to install this habit said that
intention completely it's otherwise it's
like I want to learn Italian I tried it
for six days and I'm not fluent I guess
I'm not the kind of person who can speak
Italian right so now you know what do
you do over these 60 day six days of
habit installation well it's the 202020
formula very quickly um I get into it
deeply in the book but it's the first 20
minutes the first pocket is called move
why because when you sweat first thing
in the morning you release bdnf brain
Drive neurotrophic factor which
increases the processing ability of your
brain you release dopamine that's the
inspirational
neurotransmitter you probably know this
Jay you wake up first thing in the
morning cortisol your fear hormone is
highest workout first thing in the
morning you actually increase your
metabolic rate and energy as an
entrepreneur business Builder Empire
maker history maker energy is even more
valuable than your your intellect so
that first 20 minute pocket it's now 520
you're on fire you release serotonin
you're happy even if you're cranky I
mean what's that worth then the second
pocket of the 202020 formula it's all
about reflection we live in a world
where there a lot of people who are busy
being busy but what's the point of being
busy around the wrong things just just
imagine getting to the end of the year
end of your career last day of your life
and you say you know I was incredibly
focused but I climbed the wrong
mountains so the second 20-minute pocket
you can reflect and you can write about
your you can ground in your values you
can meditate you can visualize and we
know about epigenetics we can talk about
that but as you start visualizing you
actually step into the higher version of
yourself and I love writing in a journal
I did it before I came here today I I
wrote out a written prayer of you know
serving and making a difference for all
your followers from around the world so
the second minute the second is you
anchor for the second 20 minutes and
then the final pocket is all about
growth you know the billionaires I work
with have one common denominator and
that's they're curious and they have a
white belt mentality even though they're
some of the most famous people in the
world and
so the SEC the final uh pocket is about
reading studying developing your skills
and most importantly developing yourself
step number three is read daily with
Tony Robins the first key if you're not
where you want to be is you got to feed
and strengthen your mind in other words
you you're basically what it's garbage
in garbage out we all know that right
but Jim ran was my original teacher and
he used to have this simple practice he
used to say Tony every day you got to
stand guard at the door of your mind he
asked me a question I remember early on
I was 17 years old and he said because I
was talking about some of the challenge
I was having and I wasn't getting any
support and all this bull all my wimpy
little stories and he was really kind he
just said well let me ask you a question
he said uh uh if I had a cup of coffee
if you have a cup of coffee here and he
goes um your worst enemy puts sugar in
your coffee what's going to happen I
said you're GNA have sweet coffee he
goes what if your best friend or your
parent or your or Your Lover by accident
drops one drop of strick nine in your
coffee what's going to happen he'd be
dead he goes That's Right life is both
sugar and strict KN so you better watch
your coffee stand guard at the door of
your mind and the way he used to say
that is every day take 30 minutes of
your day and read not the that comes to
you today not the clickbait where you
pick up a book and you read something
that has philosophy or psychology or
skill where you are immersing yourself
for 30 minutes in improving who you are
he said because if you do that every
single day it'll accumulate over the
decades until you'll be at a point where
you won't even believe all that you've
experienced in live step number four is
make better choices with Grant Cardone I
don't end up doing things that are
destructive when I'm busy doing things
that are constructive the truth is I was
never a drug addict I just had too much
freedom every time and made bad choices
this planet is filled with bad choices
pornography strip joints casinos if you
were filled up all day long with
activities if you were addicted to
productivity if you were junky out on
potential you wouldn't have time for all
the other garbage I would I wouldn't be
I wouldn't spend money on stuff I don't
need when is that money spent when do we
waste most of our money on this planet
during the holidays when we have free
time when do you spend your money when
do you go in debt on the holidays free
time so if I can just stay busy if I can
use time and create time how do I create
time I have 24 hours and I'm like I'm
going to jam as much in those 24 hours
as I can and then I'll let you worry
about me burning out cuz that's what
I'll hear next what about burnout when
you you're going to burnout look I'm 60
years old the more I do the more I can
do and the younger I get the more I do
the younger I feel the more I I do the
younger my body feels I'm not going to
burn out I'm not a candle I'm Not wax
the the the counselor back in in in uh
in uh the the the treatment center said
to me dude aren't you worried about CU
he he's seen my success now and he's
like aren't you worried about burning
out I'm like dude you're the burnout bro
you're the burnout you're the one that
said I was going to come back you're the
one that said I would never make it
you're the one that said uh uh don't
write books I've written seven of them
man okay you're the one that said don't
be a star I am I have TV studio right
you're the one that said Grant don't get
rich just be satisfied that you don't
use drugs again no no I got rich okay I
did the rich I did the books I did the
TV I'm going to be on a billboard I'm
going to be on a bus bro look look what
are you doing I'm not worried about
burnout I am not a candle candles
burnout Spiritual Beings don't also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life life and your business I'll
see you there Step number five is
sharpen your thinking with Tim Ferris I
would credit much of the success I've
had to whatever extent I've had success
to learning how to write and to
practicing writing and the reason for
that is that without writing it's very
hard to freeze your thinking on paper so
that you can sharpen it so that you can
see where for instance you're using
words that aren't well defined where
you're saying things that don't need to
be said all of this will help everything
else I remember in college for instance
when I took a class with John MC an
incredibly gifted writer and teacher all
of my grades in every other class went
up because every extraneous bit of
information that was hurting instead of
helping me was taken out so to sharpen
the saw a couple of different approaches
number one is write anything anything
whatsoever stream of consciousness essay
doesn't really matter let's just call it
1 to three pages something along the
lines of morning pages and Julia Cameron
the artist's way popularized this there
a number of folks like Brian cman very
well-known writer screenwriter
co-creator of the show billions swears
by morning pages so that is an easy way
to ease into the practice of just moving
a pen I recommend freehand so that you
can see your thinking on paper that
accomplishes two things number one it
takes the anxieties and nebulous worries
in your head puts them down in a freeze
frame so so that you can kind of trap
them in the printed form so you can get
on with the rest of your day the second
thing it does is it allows you to see
where you are sharp and where you are
dull in your thinking now if you are
drafting as I do for instance right now
once a week writing if you are looking
for a proof reader and you do need a
proof reader if you can't find a
professional writer because we can't all
find professional writers talk to
friends who have any type of legal
training or you could even hire a lawyer
to do this or a paralal someone with a
law degree they are trained to look at
language very very carefully because in
a dispute in a negotiation in a
disagreement arbitration it's going to
come down to the wording of contracts
and I have found that when I do not have
access to professional writers it is
often times just as good or even better
to get lawyers or people with legal
training to read my writing so that
would be a workr that I accidentally
discovered that is very powerful step
number six is adopt maximal responsib
ility with Jordan Peterson you're going
to find the meaning in your life by
adopting by adopting maximal
responsibility right that's going to be
extremely difficult because you're so
bloody useless you can't even get your
own house in order and you're and you're
going to be called upon not only to get
your house in order but to do that well
enough so some woman can stand having
you around for more than like 15 minutes
in the back of a car and then maybe
you're going to have to do it so that
you could be a good father to a family
and a pillar of the community and that's
not just empty words it's like if you do
that nobly there'll be something to you
and then when the storms come you won't
be blown over by the first 4- foot wave
and young men think huh mean I could be
something that wasn't blown over by the
first 4 foot
wave I think oh well that's that's
that's inspiring maybe that's worth
doing a little work towards it on the
off chance it might be true and the
thing about it is it is true so it's not
that difficult once you understand it to
make a case for it it's true and it's
also true that you grow in proportion to
the weight you take on voluntarily and
it's also true that we have no idea what
the upper limit to that is right so you
know you you've met remarkable people in
your life people can do remarkable
things and there are inevitably people
who take to took on remarkable burdens
and because they did that their
development was forced by necessity they
were forced by necessity to grow beyond
what they were and who knows what the
limit to that is Step number seven is
Embrace failure with Gary Vayner the one
reason that most people don't do
entrepreneurship is they do fear
failure and I think a lot about fear and
failure I think one of the great things
that happened to me was I did love
sports which meant I lost a lot and then
with school I was losing so much in
fourth fifth 6th seventh grade that by
the time I was 14 I was used to losing I
would argue I loved losing I think it's
why I love being a Jets
fan I'm being serious I'm being serious
I think that is a
characteristic of an entrepreneur and
that was a huge characteristic of mine I
think a lot about the kids that I see
now that run away from playing something
cuz they're scared to lose for me I was
the reverse I would play and play and I
would cry I cried a lot when I was a kid
if you want to know about me I cried a
lot at 9 10 11 12 but I would just get
up again and play and get up again and
play and I think we've done a terrible
job in our society on demonizing losing
when we give kids eighth place
trophies we we confuse them you you
understand we start to tell them as
parents losing is bad so we have cuz
they know I promise all the parents in
here when your kids eight and they get
an eighth place trophy they know it's
weird and when we give them that trophy
we're telling them losing is so bad we
need to like cuddle your feelings and
we're going to give you this Bullit
Trophy and what ends up happening is it
doesn't set them up for real life
because real life happens and it doesn't
work that way step number eight is do
things that scare you with Dean graos
you have to clear your calendar certain
times and do the tough stuff if selling
is the tough stuff schedule it from 2:
to 3: from 5: to 7:00 put it on your
calendar and don't allow yourself off
the hook until you do what you said
you're going to do so powerful and so
true you know I I we've been helping
Tony and I obviously we own
mastermind.com and we help people with
our programs and courses to sell what
they know to share that you're greatest
asset is your life experience how to
turn it into a course a coaching program
a podcast a workshop a book right we
obsess on that but we know sometimes
people get through all of it their life
experience is priceless all these pieces
and it's time to sell it's time to
Market sometimes the wheels come off
sometimes you get a little intimidated I
get that but if you fall in love with
what you do it's a lot easier when you
feel it's a disservice not to get them
get it to in people's hands so you can
help impact them that starts changing
but then you start got to start getting
tactical you got to start getting
repetition so here's what I challenge
you this week challenge you to look at
is where in your life do you need
Improvement okay I hope it's in your
business hope it's in
sales or I hope it's I hope you just
recognize what it is I'd recognize the
hard part is it if if it's your
relationship is is the hard part having
a conversation about a certain thing
that you really need to talk
about is it in your health is there is
there something you that you just keep
putting off I don't want to cut out the
bread I don't want to go to the gym I'm
embarrassed to go there is it in your
business is it doing the marketing is it
doing the sales is it you put put
yourself out there is afraid to go live
afraid to do a video here's my challenge
to you in this short own your future
behind the scenes podcast this week
figure out the things that you are
putting off that you are avoiding that
you're a little scared of or just a
little uncomfortable with and you just
keep working on the things that aren't
moving the needle in your life moving
the needle towards the man or the woman
you're meant to be you're kind of
putting it off till next year next month
and you'll never do it unless you do
that one thing I started this podcast
off with time to schedule it it's time
to schedule it so your challenge
recognize what you're putting off
recognize what's uncomfortable schedule
it and then the best way to make it
happen is to remind yourself why you're
doing this in the first place get
leverage when you think I don't want to
make that call but I want want freedom
with my family I want to be in control
of my calendar I want to be in control
of my life whatever it takes to get the
Leverage The Tool the asset the the the
compelling future running away from Pain
do whatever it takes to get Disturbed
with your own inaction schedule and then
hold yourself accountable for the
results that you want to
achieve we got to stop lying to
ourselves saying we're going to do
something say we want the success say we
want to make the sale say we want
freedom and then we keep letting
ourselves down because it's uncomfort
that can end today this week if you so
decide step number nine is set a good
morning routine with Jim quick you've
heard this phrase that first you create
your habits and then your habits create
you I think one of the challenges when
you are working from home or you
traveling is to establish structure
because a confused mind tends to not do
anything you may be one of those
individuals like me that needs structure
and by having a routine a set of
behaviors they provide a system
something I could go to and that reduces
something called decision fatigue a lot
of times if you have to think about
things that you are doing on a regular
basis too much it could expend a lot of
energy and one of the challenges people
report in our private Facebook group and
our app and our social media is they
just feel exhausted and part of the
exhaustion comes from using your brain
overloaded in too many ways so what I
would say is have systems and so for
example for me I have my morning routine
and you've heard me talk about this uh
maybe in our podcasts maybe in our books
and our courses some things that are
specifically for getting my mind right
first thing in the morning I believe if
you want to win the day you have to win
that first hour of the day you have to
win that morning and my goal is really
not to distract myself so when I wake up
first thing in the morning I will go
through and I will say okay what's the
most important things I get done today
cuz it's not about being busy right
we're addicted to busyness sometimes we
say oh people ask how's your day and
what are you up to it's just like I'm so
busy and and we use busyness as maybe
like a badge of honor and what we're
really saying is that we're busy so we
must be important but the goal is not to
be busy because then we start designing
our day around being busy and we wonder
why we're stressed we wonder why we are
overloaded so what I do is I say okay
let's say and do this with me please
wherever you are in your day right now
if you to fast forward at the end of the
day and somebody was to ask you a maybe
a family member or friend how was your
day and you said wow it was amazing
today was an incredible day I crushed it
reverse engineer it what had to happen
in order for you to say those words what
happened during those days what things
did you accomplish who were you being
doing sharing and so on for me I think
of three professional things I want to
accomplish I feel that if our to-do list
is 20 things or 50 things or even 100
different things then we're just being
busy the most important important things
to keep the most important things the
most important things and you could do
anything but I believe you can't do
everything certainly you can't do
everything at once so what would three
wins be for your day and step number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is be consistent with Alex
Heros can you walk me through your
stages of being willing to be consistent
and then seeing it how it's paying off
for you now yeah so I'll give three
maybe insights off of six years of
podcasts so I started July of 16
was my first podcast and I think it was
called like the gym Secrets podcast
because that's what it was called then
and this is right as I was starting gym
launch and I had gym owners who are in
my world and so I wanted to just kind of
create this is my lattice work of
thinking about how we grow gyms right
now at that point I already had six gyms
and had sold them and had done 30
turnarounds so like I had evidence that
I knew what I was talking about just for
context and so I talked about just very
like here's say fixed turn here's how
you sell membership here's how you deal
with like the spouses and their
objection here's how you can get someone
to commit to 3 days a week on your off
hour so that you can increase the
capacity of facility like here's how to
arrange your lobby so you can increase
your sales percentage like here's how
you can weave in reviews and test like I
mean just all the that you do to run a
business so number one the reason I was
able to stay consistent with it was
because it was easy for me to do because
I always try to interweave it in
my normal work schedule and so for me it
was like twice a week I would go live in
a Facebook group and I'd get questions
from all the lies of like what whatever
the issue is and if I saw a recurring
issue that would be the topic that I
would talk about so I just it was very
responsive for me and I already knew the
answer to the question and I just would
dive deep on it for X period of time and
sometimes I'd get riled up and I would
do one impromptu because someone was
like man all these leads are broke and
then I would just lose my on camera
about how they were selling out of their
own wallet and they should be trying to
help people blah blah and so that was
Insight number one is that it had to be
natural and easy for me to do to work
within my current kind of constraints
that's kind of what led to the
consistency the two things that led to
the Breakthrough at year four and a half
was number one as I rebranded the
podcast to the
game because you can imagine how many
people are like oh you got to listen to
this podcast called gym
Secrets doesn't matter what the episodes
about you're not going to listen to
unless you own a gym like it just like
why would you listen to
it and the second one or the I guess
this is Insight this is the third
Insight but the second of the
breakthroughs was that I started asking
people to share it that was it those the
the three things that changed but the
actual format itself has not really
changed I stopped talking about Jim
specific gym only in September of
19 so that was when I said I'm not going
to talk about gym stuff anymore I'm just
going to talk about Journal business and
then literally that month like the next
month it grew up and the next month it
grew the next month it grew and then
when I started saying hey if you're
enjoying this podcast like I don't run
ads I don't do anything like just share
it with a friend that was like the next
increment of growth but that was it you
know what I mean that I mean I didn't
make content anywhere else besides my C
podcast and I stayed for for four and a
half whatever it was four and a half
years at 2,000 downloads a month wow and
I feel really confident that the content
in there is still
good we've studied successful people you
know I've probably studied more
successful people than than most people
and the number one rule for success is
that you love the process you have to
like love the actual work that you're
doing that it doesn't feel like work
that it's we're all all trying to have
an impact and get results and you know
you care how many views you get Etc you
know the the external number but at the
course you still have to love the AO
process and one of the things that I
love doing is being able to pull rules
for Success from people who a lot of
people may not instantly connect with
like Connor does a lot of things that
would throw a lot of people off you know
he's a he's a lightning bolt he's he
does he does some things that rub people
the wrong way and they would never give
him um a chance at all to to hear you
know some of his wisdom but he's had a
ton of success you know and anybody
who's had a lot of success I want to
learn something from and doesn't mean
that your goal is to be the next Conor
McGregor but you could learn something
from him and I've I've tried especially
to try to learn from people who I may
not like right out of the gate for
whatever reason because they often have
the most to teach you if you only learn
from people who are exactly like you
you're you're by definition limiting how
much you learn so uh the challenge with
Connor was going through and saying okay
I mean he's got all these interviews of
him doing all sorts of crazy things
which is fine and you know Conor you do
you and there's also a lot of wisdom
there's a lot of wisdom you know if so
that video with Conor uh it wasn't him
trash talking somebody making fun of
somebody's mom or you know whatever else
but there's a lot of wisdom in there and
uh that's one of the things that I love
doing I know you all have big goals Big
Dreams big aspirations just like I do
You' got Ambitions to become an amazing
person to build your career to create to
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you you'll fall off and and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like what what happened I said I was
going to be nicer it's that you didn't
set up the most important thing you
needed to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision your journal or
set up on a vision board that you look
at once in a while but in daytoday life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this is going
to be so basic you're going to laugh and
then I'll also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you could meditate in
the morning say today I'm going to be
more present and calm and you you could
you can start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said close your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face and
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer and more more present close my
eyes take 10 deep breaths reground
myself here we go you can't do it once a
day you have to have moments throughout
the day that trigger you to enact the
new Behavior I know this makes sense to
you but it's a challenge for a lot of
people because they never set those
things up so what if you did it with an
alarm so for example for me on the
opposite Spectrum I don't want to just
be calmer and more present I Want More
Energy throughout the day so here's what
I do one of my big trigger moments is
every time my butt hits a chair I don't
care if I'm on a plane or I was like
where we're shooting here I I wrote a
lot of my books here I wrote the
motivation Manifesto here I wrote The
Charge here and if I'm going to write my
butt hits the chair I grab my phone I
open the timer and I set 50 minutes now
at 50 minutes the timer goes it starts
buzzing and I look at that and I go oh
that's my trigger to get energy so I
stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just 2 to 5 minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that
50-minute alarm and I'll work and what
that does is every 50 minutes it
triggers me to change how I'm physically
moving it changes my attention so that
throughout the day I'm continually
refreshed so I never have that 2 3 4:00
time where I'm like ah you know why
because I'm triggered my day so that my
energy is maintained throughout the day
makes sense right this could be as
simple as let's say you want to be
healthier in your life okay let's set up
some trigger moments for you in this way
let's say every time you drop off the
kids on the way back to the house you
stop at the grocery store and get some
fresh produce that's just a trigger it's
like okay did one thing drop kids off
now tied to that triggered from that
action drop kids off is go to health
food store or let's say you want to get
healthier in the morning one of the
easiest ways to help people maintain a
better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
doorf frame triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times and now when I walk through a
door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
every time they walk into a meeting into
the conference room when they walk
through the doors of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
the Dallas Uber driver oh so as somebody
who has gotten into countless Ubers and
some small percentage of them know who I
am and then of course they start asking
questions talk to me about chasing your
dreams and this quote that you have that
an aha moment does not necessarily lead
to an aha
life um yeah the Uber driver in Dallas
that's in this book um I get choked up
when I think about him uh an aha moment
why choked up I get choked up
because what happens for me every single
day is and you hear from people every
single day you've got millions and
millions of people that are inspired by
empowered by impacted by your content
there are people out there that use your
work as a
lifeline and it is humbling and what I
am really present to in the work that
I'm putting out in the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles is just how much
people are holding themselves back and
how how much pain people feel because
most folks know what they dream about
and what they
want and yet they're spending all of
their time and energy arguing against
what they want and so you can have all
these
epiphanies I hope that when somebody
listens to our conversation and watches
this that they have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean sh if you
don't take action and do something about
it the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door and most
people and that's what
was so kind
of you know the simple idea of
high-fiving yourself of encouraging
yourself of supporting yourself most
people when you have an aha moment and
the door to your new life life opens
up instead of going I got this let's go
and high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door and that's
the problem I want to attack right now
that there is somewhere in your life
that you know what you want you can feel
it pulling you and you are actively
arguing against it you're bringing
yourself down you're beating yourself
out like people will cheer for you and
me they won't cheer for themselves I'm
the same way and so this Uber driver the
story that you're talking about I get
into the car and we start driving and
I'm on the phone as we're driving and
I'm having a conversation with somebody
about this daytime talk show that I
launched which was a dream with Sony
Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one won it
was a huge failure because we didn't
make it to season
2 huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life and so I'm talking
to this person about the talk show I
hang up the phone and this Uber driver
comes alive he's like oh my gosh I can't
believe you're in my cab and I'm like
why and he says because I I want to talk
to you about something I think you can
help me and I'm like great how can I
help you and he says I have a dream of
being a Oscar winning uh actor and
creating opportunities for other black
and Latino men to do the same in acting
and I'm like freaking fantastic what the
are you doing in Dallas right you know
the guy's 25 and so I I go you know the
game is in New York and La I mean sure
you can act you can write stuff you can
be here in Dallas but why are you not in
La why are you not in New York and he's
like you're right you're right you're
right I need to move to LA like why not
and says I have $700 in my bank account
I'm like that's freaking fantastic you
have $700 in a car dude drop me off and
get driving what are you waiting for and
so we have this whole conversation and I
write about it in this book where I am
actively arguing for his dream and he is
actively arguing against his
dream and what is so sad is through out
this conversation Tom he's like you're
right $700 could get me there you're
right I am only 25 you're right if I
keep thinking and thinking and thinking
and thinking about what I want to be
doing I'm not only going to drive in
circles my whole life is going to spin
in circles as I think about what I want
and I don't do sh about it and then you
are going to find yourself not at 25 but
at 45 or 65 and you're going to be so
filled with regret that you never put a
put a bet on yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not I don't
know the point of the story is it's so
easy to see what somebody else should do
it's so easy to cheer for somebody else
we all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves it
dawned on me
that sometimes we don't have the right
frames when we're doing something and we
don't um give things the right
meanings and let me explain what I mean
to you by
that when we uh start something new I
think sometimes we
forget that anything that is new to our
brain uh may be exciting and uh May
release dopamine the neurochemical that
uh you know is the reward
neurochemical and uh we feel good cuz
we've taken on this new Endeavor whether
it's a new language whether it's
retraining our brain uh whether it's um
starting to exercise or eating better or
committing to doing something that's of
benefit to us or even stopping
something now the very nature of how our
brain works is that patterns that have
been repeated over you know months and
years are the dominant patterns in our
brain and therefore it's easier for our
brain to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know a highway system
that's been built it's easy for the cars
to go faster on the highway system well
the same thing is true with our brain
and the neural networks and Pathways so
the U pathways are the easy easiest for
the um chemicals to travel across um and
release the um neurochemicals you know
that make us feel good or make us feel
fearful or make us feel apprehensive or
doubtful Etc uh are the ones that are
the easiest for our brain to activate
and follow through on okay part one so
that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
uh it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-tooth
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy
conservation um mindset without even
knowing it uh our biology is geared
towards doing things that are easy for
us not things that require
energy right
glucose so why am I sharing this with
you well as you're you know on your
journey of brain training upgrading your
Knowledge and Skills taking actions
probably different actions than you were
taking to achieve the results that you
want more and better results from of um
it requires you uh accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially when you feel resistance now
I came out here I still have my workout
gloves on because as I was doing uh some
ab work as I was doing you know some um
bench press and flies for my chest one
of the things that dawned on me is most
people do things that they're
comfortable doing but in order to get
stronger from a cardiovascular
perspective you have to challenge
yourself mix up your routines you've got
to go a little bit longer a little bit
harder um uh you know on the days that
you want to expand your capabilities so
in the world of uh you know doing
weights for strength training or
building muscle there are certain
techniques uh to use and certain
strategies to use including rest right
uh muscles build built in the rest phase
so let me explain what I'm talking about
I think you know where I'm going with
this when I let's say do a bench press
or a fly or I walk up a
hill the place where it's the hardest
where there's resistance where I want to
quit and stop and I'm breathing heavier
I just can't do another rep that's the
point of the
growth and the more you practice at that
place right the resistance the point of
I want to quit I can't do it anymore
that is how you expand your capacity
resistance happens when you're at the
edges of Your Capacity now it could be
mental edges emotional edges physical
edges Financial edges and how does it
show up it shows up as
stress right stress so stress happens
when your current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds the
demand your current capacity exceeds the
demand so how do you increase demand I'm
sorry how do you increase capacity well
you feel the edges and go one more you
feel the tension and keep doing it you
feel the desire to quit but then you do
as much as you can and as you do as much
as you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when when I feel like let's say
quitting I just say just a little bit
more when I don't feel like it I say I
know but just do a little bit why cuz I
want to override my natural and your
natural propensity to want to quit to
want to stop it's natural but I don't
want to be natural I want to be
Supernatural I don't want to be ordinary
I want to be extraordinary and that's
that little extra does that make sense
so as you're training your brain uh as
you have videos to watch upgrade your
Knowledge and Skills as you have events
to attend you know to to connect to to
listen to learn to
expand if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
healthwise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results I think the
challenge
that you have when you're good is that
you're good
yeah so you're like I'm doing pretty
good already yeah it's e the the better
you get the more expertise development
you get the easier it is to show up and
go through the motions yeah you don't
have to prepare as much you don't have
to practice as much you just you results
whatever going to do is good enough yeah
but what happens with Hyper it eats at
them because they know they got more in
the tank and they're like you know what
that was good but I could have got
another and it's not that they're
dissatisfied we take on that myth in
this book High performers are not
dissatisfied so people who say never be
satisfied they got to look look at why
they're saying that cuz it's not true
cuz High performers are satisfied
they're they're striving satisfied
doesn't mean they're not striving for
the next big thing want to become better
but they're happy hyper are happier than
all of their peers I mean by significant
almost double digits so it's really
significant um but I think for me I need
to constantly be reminding myself like
okay what is the reason you need to
perform really well right now and I need
to be more consistent about that
question um so I set up triggers in my
life to do that you know um from every
time I stand in line I have a line
trigger I have door triggers I have
phone triggers you know so when I stand
in line I always say what level am I
right now in terms of my presence and
energy scale one to 10 one I suck I'm
dead I'm not even alive not even feeling
grateful you know 10 I'm like I'm VI I'm
joyous here I am um and I I rate myself
consistently on that and it just
retouches me like the KNE I want to feel
it's necessary to be grateful I want to
feel it's necessary to be great I want
to feel it's necessary to do my best but
you don't get that without reminders so
you got to set up alarms or triggers or
some you know note cards on the whatever
it is takes for you to have that but I
know for me raay after the research I
didn't get how I mean I me you're
talking from every athlete to every High
CEO to this is what they did they're and
I didn't find this you'll see all the
questions I asked them in the book I
really had to dial into their psyche and
when we found that I was like is that a
thing that they' really that's I mean
but they all do I would say maybe not
the most popular answer go to the fear
how are you going to look silly or
stupid you're not going to ask
questions and you're going to end up in
the wrong place and people like why
don't you just ask like follow the fear
if the fear says I'm scared I'm look
stupid by asking questions like well
let's flip that cuz if you don't ask
questions you're definitely going to
look stupid those who learn to endure
hardship struggle challenge difficulty
pain grief V ability failure um
regret that's one side of that
coin if you learn to do that but you
also don't on the other side learn to
allow Joy fulfillment satisfaction a a
sense of now hold on hold onow stop you
allow is that the word you want to
commit to you said bring I'm going to
build build it you have to first allow
it cuz what most people do
is if on the other side of the coin it's
super etched
in what happens is even when that
impulse comes up to I like this oh no
I'm not supposed to like it this is so
you have a lot of people who are
extremely talented at the top levels who
they do endure the pain and they really
like the pain and they will allow that
all the day long they'll allow that that
now cuz they'll tell their brain this is
what it's expected but they also don't
let themselves feel good when feeling
good is there this is a real big problem
I mean if you studied like psychosis a
lot of people who really struggle with
addictions um Eating Disorders are super
common who even when they feel that
sense of self-love or self accept oh I'm
not supposed to feel that no you really
there is an element to personal devel
where you have to allow the good
feelings and not push them away because
it's like oh I should I don't deserve to
feel that cuz a huge part of the world
is telling themselves I don't yet
deserve to feel
happy even though happiness comes up I'm
I shouldn't feel that yet I'm going to
keep striving it's not until I get the
next 2 million then I'll let myself feel
happy even though they had that good
Monday and so you have a lot of people
who are striving in difficulty who also
have not taught themselves the emotional
side
of what is called the most important
movement in the history of the world in
Psychology called positive psychology
kicked off by Marty cigman a good friend
of mine sent me high without that work
of saying no no we also have to allow
ourselves and teach ourselves to
flourish feel satisfaction feel Joy so
I'm 100% with you and I'm like the rule
is that's one side of the coin and the
other rule is make sure you teach
yourself to generate the positive
emotions because what happens is if you
don't teach yourself to generate the
positive emotions as well then what ends
up happening is you burn out or you
become a cliche of the person who had it
all and never felt fulfilled think of
your life as being a productively
fulfilling
life that productivity is not a a time
management
thing it's a purpose
thing I don't think of time management
when I think of productivity I think of
purpose I think of who do I want to be
what do I want to
contribute what will be fulfilling for
me because if you don't have something
bigger than just blocks of time which
are important but there's not something
that we together are going towards where
it's this set of Dreams
where there's personal meaning and there
is social
contribution we won't go the first
lesson today in about sort of having
patience for your dream is you have to
work on it every single day for at least
30 minutes or don't fool yourself that
it's going to happen you know we all
hope that one day we'll get a bunch of
free weekends or a month off or three
months off and that's when we'll finally
start working towards our thing you got
to do it every day
where that means you research every day
you read every day you study every day
you take a course every day or you
actually create everything on that thing
every day you're just working at it book
authors they write every day not all of
them but a lot of the greats wrote every
single day right and it just forcing
ourselves to really be in the game now
not everybody writes every day not
everyone needs to create every day some
people can just have a marvelous 18 days
and they've written the greatest book of
all time but that rarely happens it
rarely happens happens and those folks
tend to be like Masters or savants or
Geniuses regular folks myself included I
got to work every day towards my dreams
every day I honed in something about
this and if you didn't know something
about me I do everything in this
business right I'm shooting this video
right now but I mean I picked the
materials for this thing I chose the
fonts I designed all the pages I mean I
wrote the back cover the front cover the
inside stuff it's like I do the projects
of my dreams let go of the
baggage you're never going to touch the
full rim of your potential if you're
weighted down by baggage from your
Elementary School years your high school
years your college Years these last four
years listen the last chapters of the
book you gone through them you finished
them you flipped the page you got a new
chapter here and you have to be willing
to break from the past to have the
future you so desperately desire
you have to have the courage to allow
yourself to honor the past as it was to
forgive those who need to be
forgiven to forgive
yourself and to acknowledge that
everything LED you to this point now
everything those crappy times those
times when you're depressed those times
when you gave up on yourself those times
when someone else gave up on you those
times that you gave up on others the
times that you quit the times that you
failed the times that you felt so small
you
embarrassed those times don't live in
this
moment and the more of those times that
you cultivate in your mind and you
ruminate on and you think and you
self-talk on and you revisit in your
mind the more disempowering times from
the past hurtful times from the past
failures from the past that you keep
running in your head what that is doing
is that is taking up the very free space
necessary for the Bold ideas to come in
it's taking up the space for the very
needed white space for creativity to
come in for the dreams to come in for
the best you to speak through
from like it's hard for you to live an
authentic and true and vulnerable and
real life if you're always speaking
through your baggage if you're always
thinking through your baggage and you
guys know what I'm talking like
everyone's got different baggage maybe
your may maybe your baggage is your
divorce or that last job they are not
relevant today and the only reason
they're relevant today is If either you
allow them to be relevant from those
situations or those persons revisiting
you or you're running the same old story
you're running the same old excuses yeah
I can't do this because I suck at
relationships no you suck the
relationships 10 years ago well I can't
do this because you know uh I I failed
yeah 6 months ago today's a new day
homie like you got to access this day
dude this day is fresh this day is clean
this day woke up showered ready prepped
for you by the universe or Spirit or God
or luck or Cosmos whatever you want to
call it this day says to you when you
wake up in the morning the day Whispers
to you do not fear me for I have been
brought here for
you you don't fear the day that day has
been brought here for you I talk to so
many smart fantastic ambitious
idealistic hardworking kids and they're
right out of college they're in their
entry-level jobs and I'll ask them how's
it going and they'll say I think I'm
going to quit and I'm like why they say
to me I'm not making an impact I'm like
you know you've been here eight months
right they treat the sense of
fulfillment or even love like it's a
scavenger hunt like it's something you
look for my Millennial friends they've
gone through so many jobs they're either
getting fired I mean it was
Mutual or they're quitting because
they're not making an impact or they're
not finding the thing they're looking
for they're not feeling fulfilled as if
it's a scavenger hunt love a job you
find Joy from is not something you
discover it's not like I Found Love here
it is I found a job by love that's not
how it works both of those things
require hard work you are in love
because you work very hard every single
day of your life to stay in love you
find a job that brings you ultimate Joy
because you work hard every single day
to serve those around you and you
maintain that Joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't say is the mountain this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are
journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next dump
and on to the next ghost and on to the
next and by the way ghosting means the
lack of skill to have a
confrontation you date somebody for 6
months8 months and then just stop
replying just delete them from
everything now for the person who's
doing the ghosting oh that's certainly
easier than a confrontation but the
person on the receiving end of the
ghosting it's like there's a death
they're suddenly shunned there's Panic
they call out their wored they call out
their word they think it's you they
think it's them do you have any idea the
destruction that we reap on people by
ghosting them and then because there's
the lack of social skills to call out
and ask for help they internalize and it
makes them feel awful to the point at
the worst they will kill themselves
slightly one level down they'll get
depressed but the lowest level that we
can hope for is they will go through
life and I'm not talking about ghosting
I'm talking an entire generation that if
we don't fix this we'll go through life
where everything's just fine my
friendships are fine my work is fine you
know same old same old nothing's ever
amazing and the scavenger hunt
continues and then you go to the fourth
observation the most egregious of all of
them
environment we're taking a generation
that has lower self-esteem we're taking
a generation that has a lack of cop
coping mechanisms to deal with stress
we're C dealing with a a generation that
wants all those things fixed immediately
and we're placing them in work
environments that values money more than
people do you know that most of the
business philosophies most of the
business theories that we Embrace and
see as standard today are not standard
their theories left over from the 80s
and 90s the concept of shareholder
Supremacy was a theory proposed in the
late 1970s it was popularized in the 80s
and 90s the concept of using mass
layoffs to balance the books did not
exist in the United States prior to the
1980s it did not
exist it became popular in the 80s and
'90s the 80s and 90s were boom
years anyone could make money relative
peace a Kinder gentler Cold War and so
all of the business theories they were
put forth were very very selfish and all
about enrich
ourselves and they worked for those
times but these times are different
these are not peaceful times these are
not boom years this is there's
globalization in the internet which has
now made everything vastly more
complicated and those theories do not
work anymore worse they're having side
effects it's really bad because what we
do is we destroy corporate cultures the
idea of using mass layups can you
imagine sending someone home and saying
I'm sorry I can no longer provide for
our family because the company missed
its arbitrary projections this year
that's what we're doing that's like a a
coach prioritizing the needs of the fans
over the needs of the players hoping to
build a great team it doesn't work we
dismantled things like the glass steagle
act glass steagle was passed after the
Great Depression to prevent another
Great Depression from happening it was
dismantled in the 80s and '90s in the
name of
profit okay do you know how many stock
market crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of glass
Eagle the answer is
zero and since they dismantle glass
deagle we had 87 the dot crash 2008
we've had three stock market crashes
because we've moved the safety
mechanisms that prevent stock market
crashes from happening all in the name
of individual advancement and profit and
these are the corporate cultures we've
built corporate cultures that value
numbers over people and they are not
standard business practices they are new
and they are broken and they are
dangerous and we're asking a young
wonderful ambitious amazing generation
that needs us to work in these
environments whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for the
bad hand that you've been dealt it is up
to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence it is up to the
companies to create an
environment in which you can learn
coping mechanisms and learn how to build
strong close relationships with people
with whom you work that you will
eventually love and sacrifice to see
that they
gain it is in these environments that we
will learn the patience and the hard
work that it takes to find fulfillment
in our lives to find find a sense of
purpose a sense of
Joy yes it's all fine and good that my
generation and older Generations say to
you things like well you're the Future
Leaders we're the leaders
now we're the ones in control of the
corporate environments
now and we're making your lives
worse I don't want you to jump from job
to job to job to job you will never find
what you're looking for it's not a
scavenger hunt I don't want you to go
from relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you
properly nobody wants to wake up in the
morning and be managed we want to wake
up in the morning and be led and we have
a total leadership crisis in America
politics is just the mirror reflection
we get the politicians we deserve We're
The Divided ones we're the selfish ones
we're the broken ones we're the ones who
would soona sacrifice somebody else so
that we may gain it's us and it's until
we're willing to do the hard work of
repairing the world around us our
country our politics our businesses will
not
fix if you want to learn to get wealthy
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there start young the
big thing about it is we started
building this little snowball on top of
a very long hill so we started at a very
early age and rolling the snowball down
and of course the snowball the nature of
compound interest is it behaves like a
snowball of